how is selling a reality show evolved in
the last 20 years I think it's much the
same as it ever was a good idea is a
good idea but I also think that we're
also way more reliant on importing
existing Concepts from other countries
you look at things like The Masked
Singer where an executive was literally
in a restaurant having dinner and
watching that show on television and
went oh we should make that
that's different
I mean we're we're more exposed to
formats from other places than we've
ever been because people are looking for
them
they're trying to find something that's
already proven that they don't have to
lose money on while they develop it
so that may be a little bit different
you see the rise of guys like aviarmoza
who is one of my favorite people in the
world
um he's just a really cool guy who
packages formats uh in Israel
that that's actually where you make most
of your money because if you're
producing television shows in Israel
it's a very middle class Pursuit it's
not something that you really make a
fortune doing
but you have certain examples you know
there's a show called couch diaries that
comes from there which is a great idea
you just you get a passport
you take somebody to the airport you
don't tell them where they're going they
find out when they get to the airport
and they're going to a place that's
going to help them overcome some issue
they have in their life like there was a
kid that was terrified of women and they
sent him to room with these three women
around the same age as him they took him
out showed him a good time he had a
great time and just was suddenly became
more comfortable around them they took a
woman who was very sort of uh
[Music]
mild-mannered and very religious and
very proper Center someplace to live
with a family that didn't observe the
same religion that she did they got used
to each other and had that experience
that show has been sold in something
like 15 or 20 territories the world over
and the Creator uh Zippy Rosenblum
which is the greatest name you've ever
heard in your life isn't it uh Zippy
Rosenbloom is now an executive I think
with hachette
so you know the idea that formats can be
repackaged and resold all over the world
uh is kind of a neat thing I think it's
a great way for creators in other places
to get seen in the United States which
is no longer seen as the end-all beetle
like if it's not on American television
it doesn't exist which is kind of how
people used to think
um
I guess I'll stop there
do you have to be working inside reality
television to sell a show
it's not unhelpful I was in it for about
eight years before I knew enough people
that I felt like I could call somebody
up and go
and that was even with an agency
I had a really decent agent and I just I
didn't I didn't want to expose myself
before I was ready and really knew the
full
deal on how you should be pitching
so I waited until I was ready and it's
much better to try to pitch after you
have connections and you have titles I
got my agent after I worked was working
on the osbornes
so I would start calling people and go
hi it's Troy default from Over The
Osbournes and they go oh I don't know
who you are but I know the name of that
show it was very easy to get meetings
so a person sort of fresh here in LA
with no connections not working in the
industry but they have this amazing idea
is that possible they can actually it is
not unheard of but it is really hard if
you have talent attached you know if
your brother-in-law is a quarterback for
a football team and you think that he
would be great as the subject of a show
and he has said yes
go for it but it's very rarely
done did somebody completely fresh to
things gets something sold you've got to
bring something with you
you've got to figure out where your
value is
as a producer if you've never done it
before there isn't anything that you
bring to the actual production so
give yourself enough time to get
acquainted with some people and
make yourself bigger by associating with
people that can pitch with you
I always pitch through an existing
production company that has an existing
relationship with whatever Network I
think is right for the show
and that's just easier for everybody
because the credibility line is
established
who are the players involved in a show
being sold
well you've got the production company
which you've got the people who do
development at those production
companies the people who have existing
relationships with the network it's
Network Executives obviously have
something to say whoever's in
development whoever's in programming and
current series
uh those are the people that you want to
get interested in the in the work
how is selling a reality show different
from selling a screenplay or a movie
screenplay or movie is more of a
solitary thing coming out of the gate
um a movie is going to go through
several iterations and you're probably
going to be fired off the film and
they'll bring on another writer who's
established to complete that
if you have not read Tom Lennon and
baron Ben garin's book uh that's called
making Movies for Fun and Profit and Fun
and Profit is crossed out so it's making
movies for profit
um they detail that pretty well about
how fear that if you're the writer that
starts
you know you'll get assault if it's a
reality show
I mean everything is super collaborative
but a reality show probably has more
fingers in the fudge than almost
anything because everybody thinks they
can contribute to a reality program why
do you think that is because it's
perceived as something that's easier to
do
erroneously
but it's also you know
I think people have more of an idea of
how a reality show gets made than they
do of how a film gets made
they assume that it's a you know just
kind of this massive Beetle Bailey cloud
of flying fists and action that somehow
settles into a finished product
I think you've said never blindly email
anyone anything in the entertainment
industry right
I would say that because uh email is so
immediate it's like teleporting into
somebody's living room in your
underpants and wanting to have a
conversation with them
if you go through a Channel or you meet
them through someone that you know
uh then it makes sense if you're blindly
emailing people all day get unsolicited
contact
and it also is a very amateurish way to
move forward
if you're going to email somebody do it
in a way where it's like
the indicate that you know something
about them and be asking them for advice
as opposed to asking them for action on
your behalf
because when you write to someone and
you say
I like a lot of things that you do I'm a
little confused about the process I'm
trying to get started I have this thing
that I'm trying to move forward with
don't attach
any documents that they would have to
read and expose themselves to the
liability if somebody else is making a
show similar to yours to the Jew and a
lawyer stand up at some point and go we
should sue them because that's just like
the thing we pitched that they never
wanted to look at but they'll emailed to
them
and on social media as well some certain
platforms are wonderful but people can
be very hyper visual yeah for heaven's
sakes don't talk about the thing you're
trying to sell on social media
oh not only that I'm sorry I meant uh in
terms of trying to contact people
blindly again with an ask for them
rather than right something could you
read this for me sure nobody wants to
read I still think I still think every
day about that thing that Josh Olson
wrote years ago that I don't want to
read your [__] script
it's a it's a great read it's like I
have a pile of stuff next to my bed from
my friends that I need to read I have
things I have to write I have things I
have to do I cannot stop and take the
amount of time that it takes to read a
screenplay to give somebody that I don't
know advice
so that being said because that's
disheartening to hear I realize that
that is most people they're inundated
with sure the reality of this business
are very hard to hear that's true okay
but how do we how do we overcome that in
the sense of uh okay if it's an unknown
and they have several screenplays they'd
like to have made
what are the proper channels
the proper channels are uh to look for
representation
um it's very hard to get anybody to read
anything if it's not coming to them uh
through an agent the old phrase over you
know over the transom nobody reads
things that just pop in through the
window
it's not a subpoena you don't tap
somebody on the shoulder and they have
to read it
okay so find representation what if they
can't find that
you can use an entertainment attorney
that has decent relationships with
people to submit things
um it's a little more rare and it's not
going to be free they're going to take a
percentage of whatever you make off of
that sale just like an agent would or
ask you for an upfront fee
um
you just have to be prepared for that